[Music]
anybody can be a [ __ ] scribe I was
quite taken aback by how quickly I got
swept away by the romance
you
you look amazing how do you feel in that
one I feel amazing and briefs can't wait
to settle down with her English fiance
Ben I'm civil ceremony where I should be
on the 19th of May so I think there's
another wedding going on so once told me
I'm not sure it's gonna be international
wedding is interracial wedding she's
quite open about and very proud about
the fact that she's a mixed-race I think
that only is going to be beneficial
because I am an interracial relationship
and bringing that to the foreground into
the mainstream that's only gonna
hopefully be have a positive impact and
I think she's handling it with elegance
and grace in regards to some of the and
kind of nasty attacks that she's had
based off of her race
I think it's only positive
[Music]
this is the first royal wedding where
the bride's ethnicity has made headlines
a mixed-race American actress whose
ancestors were slaves marrying a British
Prince since Megan herself has been so
outspoken about racial equality some see
this marriage as a game changer and a
victory for diversity I'm really just
proud of Who I am and where I come from
and we have never put any focus on that
we've just focused on who we are as a
couple for me it's a added member of the
family it's another another team player
as part of the bigger team
congratulations from all of us
I'm Megan how you feeling
and tell us how did you propose
was it romantic when Nova Reed was
getting married she found there was very
little out there for brides like her so
set up a blog and often works with
designer Ian Stewart what we try to do
here is to really custom create the gown
for the client
women want they don't want to look like
everybody else but if we can't see it
represented we don't think it exists for
oh my gosh she's a gorgeous aren't they
I started by more magazines and it was
the same thing sometimes I would flick
through them and there would be not one
single person of color in the entire
magazine and as I became more into the
industry and going to wedding shows and
wedding fairs it was the same on the
catwalk I'd be given goody bags with
tanning products in it so it's like I
wasn't being thought of as a black woman
I wasn't people weren't expecting me to
be coming through the doors and spending
money so I thought hold on a second
there's there's a niche here let me
create something I've got an idea you
flick through that one I'll flick
through this one and let's try and find
black bride shall we and that lack of
representation doesn't stop with the
wedding industry creating a sense of
alienation I grew up in Hartford cher
and I was a minority and I became
acutely aware that I was different to my
peers and everyone around me so as a
young girl I loved watching Disney but I
never associated myself as being a
princess as being desirable in that way
because everything that was preferred
and offered to me on the TV even in
popular culture didn't look like me most
of the representations of people with
the same skin as me were children in
poverty charity adverts asking for
people to donate so it brought all that
stuff up again I thought with decades
later why am i why is this still thing
on the face of it you would think this
future princess is getting to know a
diverse and inclusive United Kingdom the
last census showed the number of people
classed as white British is declining
and one in ten couples are interracial
but race and how we talk about it can
split families and communities a recent
report found that one in four people
admits being racially prejudiced Prince
Harry
complained about what he said with the
racial undertones of reports about his
fiancee there's basically two ways and
leaders and the Daily Mail came out
previously 2016 the headline was Prince
Harry's girlfriend is almost straight
out of Compton and it's a really racist
tale about how a mother lives in the
American ghetto could the could the
Queen be able to go around for a cup of
tea and to run all these really negative
stereotypes on black people and in the
second kind of reaction from the media
there's been this the kind of downplayed
of fact that she's black a tool so she
looks like people Middleton well she's
gonna be like Diane Prince it ain't like
dr. clay Andy Andrews from Birmingham
City University is deeply skeptical
about all the hype around the wedding
and the perception it'll somehow improve
things for black people one of my PhD
students a young black woman passed one
the TV announcement came out and they
were gonna have this wedding her
neighbor who was an older white lady
came made a special trip to come out of
her house come around knock on the door
just to tell my PhD student they
actually thought he was terrible that he
thought the monarchy should stay white
and she wasn't happy at all
and she went back to it and carried on
with him you are kidding so she bothered
to come out of her house just to tell
your student but she wasn't happy about
it yes
and that also tells you some of the
honesty that you get maybe from that
whole de jure generation
so the royal family is probably a
premier institution of whiteness if you
look at the idea of the empire the
Commonwealth the time when Britain was
great and return year ruled the waves
five chieftains boarded the liner to bid
the Queen welcome to the islands it's
not coincidence that 68% of people think
that colonialism was a good thing and
about 68 percent of people believe that
the monarchy is a good thing as well all
right so the Monica is this is this kind
of symbol of many of the problems with
Britain and how it relates to race how
many of you know put any of the royal
family how many but what is the reality
of being black or mixed race in Britain
today at this youth club they encourage
the kids to identify people that they
feel they can look up to how many people
think it's a good thing that's Megan and
Harriet that you married I want to see
the hands off so it's one two three four
five what do you know about Prince Harry
and Megan Markel do you know anything
about it excited what do you think of
Megan and who else do you look up to who
were like the people that you admire
what's going on in here we've got a team
leader and we're making some toast and
stuff okay to an epigram set up the
ebony and ivory community group nine
years ago when I started this all them
years ago it was Connie came from two
young girls that said to me I have
nothing for me so I wanted to hopefully
bring chill bring children together and
work with them and nine years on have
you still got kids coming through the
door saying maybe more because whether
it's what the government called
austerity or whether I don't know the
the issues around the international or
national issues that are happening like
brixi or whatever I don't know
talked people like uber and they'll tell
you that feeling of discrimination
filters into everything from policing to
job prospects education to housing
the government's first-ever race
disparity audit found that ethnic
minority households are more likely to
be poor and most likely to be in
persistent poverty they don't go out
with a house at all Fridays their only
outlet you know outside of school that's
why it's so busy all the time by 4
o'clock sometimes they're waiting
outside we don't start till about 5:00 a
so they come straight from state from
scope and then we will get some food for
them
[Music]
less than a quarter of black children in
Stockport reach the standard set for 11
year olds in reading and maths
Giada is 15 and wants to be a lawyer you
field because of the color of your skin
you're treated differently going through
high school you always experienced some
sort of bullying but then I feel like
that come that goes that increases for
me because I am my skin color and like
one of my classmates and was having an
argument with her friends today they
were arguing it was something and then
then she goes - oh you're a slave
they take the mickey out of slavery yes
some of them do try and be sack up I
guess it was a job where there's so say
things about it every black male
academically tell you they get hassled
by security they got stopped because
they think they're a student I have
colleagues who've been literally
somebody physically try to escort them
away from their office because they
thought no joint a break-in so every day
actually go to work I go to work in
trousers and very smart have my name
bags right around my neck so everybody
can see it and it's something that you
just have to do because to not do it is
to always seem to be suspect tune always
seem to be problematic if you've been
served in a shop and you notice the the
shopkeeper having wonderful
conversations or just small talk with
customers in front of you who do not
share the same skin tone and then you
come and you be served and there's no
eye contact there's no conversation and
your money isn't placed in your hand
like the pier before it's placed on the
counter for you to pick up yourself so
it's these tiny tiny things are really
hard to call out sometimes
that that make you recognize that you're
still seen as another I lean on bin al
in a lean on my fiance to kind of give
me that strength whenever I feel a bit
uncomfortable or maybe I feel like
people are staring a little bit too long
as Megan gets to know the UK they
visited places where you can't help but
talk about immigration and diversity it
was striking that they were the royal
representatives at a service for
teenagers Stephen Lawrence who was
murdered by a racist gang 25 years ago
now as part of the establishment can she
really use her new role to challenge
inequality
[Applause]
[Music]
try and encourage others and the younger
generation to be able to see the world
in the correct sense rather than having
a distorted view of course it's
disheartening it's a shame that that is
the climate in this world to focus that
much on that or that that would be
discriminatory it's not good or bad
but it will have absolutely no impact on
racism in reality Britain doesn't like
to admit its colonial that to have
something positive which i think is what
Megan stands for I think it's a
wonderful thing for young girls to see
different variations of beauty and
strength
[Music]